all right a lot of requests for me to
talk about this show but first i do want
to thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by amc plus and
their epic world
shows like season 10 of the walking dead
and the talking dead if you're one of
the ones out there who likes hearing the
creative process you know likes hearing
the interviews with the cast
i do i love that stuff you know me i
love halloween i love the season i love
the halloween spirit last october for
the entire month i just did
horror movie reviews anything to keep
the spirit alive and some of you may say
nay
jeremy halloween is six months behind us
this is madness to me that's just an
interesting way of saying
we are now halfway to halloween and
since it shutters halfway to halloween
celebrating that fact you can also
celebrate with shutters creep show
because just because we binge halloween
movies
on that season doesn't mean we can't
keep it alive the other 364.
so click the link below get your seven
day free trial and join me in keeping
the halloween spirit alive year round
and thank you once again to amc plus for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now talking
about the much requested invincible
couple things this is a spoiler free
review so no spoilers in this video
which means
i'm gonna have to tread lightly i'm
gonna navigate this video not spoiling
anything which might disappoint some of
you i feel like some people out there
wanna hear me talk about invincible in
that spoiler capacity but the video is
not going to be that
because part of the joy of invincible is
not knowing which also means if you
don't know invincible haven't read
invincible haven't watched invincible
though as i'm describing it it might
sound a bit
generic but it's not as generic in its
execution as it might come across
in my video just know that so setting it
up invincible is an
animated superhero series it's on amazon
prime based off of the graphic novels
written by robert kirkman who wrote the
walking dead graphic novels and you
definitely see that this is
very kirkman's style which i appreciate
the fact that it does
feel like his style i also love the fact
that he worked very closely with this
series and getting it made there are two
kinds
of writers out there writers where when
their things are adapted they're like
if i don't work closely with this it's
not actually going to do it justice and
there's alan moore out there who's like
they made an adaptation of that i
haven't given a since league of
extraordinary gentlemen i
don't know what to say two very
different mindsets but i get both of
them but the world of invincible takes
place in a world where
superheroes are out there people have
superpowers and some are superheroes
follows mark grayson whose father
is omniman he's pretty much this world
superman who's like i need to make
this world a better place and right
there this is why i get the mindset of
like this
seems very familiar because when i was
watching this i was like this seems like
someone
made the boys again like oh the boys
it's this adult
take on the superhero tropes and okay
you even have
your justice league characters in here
you have the fast character you have the
water character you have the wonder
woman character you have the superman
character but that is not giving this
series its due credit though that's
probably going to be the response of a
lot of people
when you first start the first episode
but this show does a very good job at
being its own thing carving its own path
in the world of entertainment this video
is already very jumpy because i need to
go back to
to mark grayson as it's following him he
finally gets
his superpowers and becomes a superhero
which it does in every episode someone
before they say the word invincible it
cuts to title of invincible
with the amazing detail that a new blood
spatter comes on the screen
every time but the old one stays so by
the end
yeah and top-notch voice acting at first
i mean jk simmons being omni-man that's
the one you recognize right out the gate
and he's amazing in the show because jk
simmons
is a very complex voice actor and actor
everything that he needs to be in this
show
jk simmons is the perfect casting for
omnimax but stephen young plays mark
grayson who i mean he's at the front
center of the show it's
his show it's his complex life that
we're dealing with here he's a great
actor we all know it
he's also very likable also some great
support characters and invincible not
gonna go into too much detail if i do a
spoiler video i will but cecil and robot
were among my favorites the reason i
wanted to talk about this show is
because
after watching it i was i was met with
the feeling of
i ingest a lot of entertainment out
there you might too i don't know
or maybe you don't maybe you're like i
just like watching jump cutting youtube
people with red backgrounds if so bless
you but odds are
you know we've seen a lot of stuff a lot
of superhero stuff because a lot of
things are superhero stuff now superhero
movies superhero shows superhero
spin-offs
superhero comedies that aren't good
everyone trying to capitalize on the
superhero thing so if a superhero series
comes around and makes me go
oh that was something special i want to
talk about i mean yeah this show deals
with a teenage superhero getting his
super powers
figuring it out becoming a superhero for
the first time balancing his dating life
and a superhero live you know it just
sounds like things you've heard and seen
before but it's the detail of the show
that i really love whether it's
the detail of the animation which is
amazing by the way every hit you feel
every splatter of blood you taste
that's in tandem with the animation and
the sound design but it's also the
attention to detail that is the building
blocks of the world itself one of which
was there's this
demon investigator because there's this
investigative element here trying to
figure out all right
what's going on and why so you have this
demon investigator which is also the
hellboy-ish character but you know the
tales if there's a haunted house if
there's an evil presence a demon in the
room
it gets cold there's a scene where
someone's talking you start seeing his
breath and he's like
give me the room and then everyone has
to leave he's like all right what's up
and then demon appears that's just a
neat detail rather
than just having the demon show up okay
i'm here now every action has a reaction
the demon being there would make the
room cold but the room would get cold
before the demon shows himself also
there's a fight someone gets into where
someone
tries to gouge their eyes out with their
thumbs so for the entirety of the next
episode
dude's eyes are just bloodshot in pink
now most shows would be like yeah his
eyes will be bloodshot in pink maybe for
the rest of the episode
maybe definitely for the next scene
after that but it's like they'll just
end up forgetting that it ever happens
but today's a new day because the
episode's a new episode
but to the characters in the world it's
not a new day so for that next episode
i should be bloodshot in pink and in
this show they are i don't know why i
appreciated that
so much but it's just that kind of
attention to detail that
i would hope i had also when i talk
about splatting of blood and sound
design and yeah
the show's very violent but it's not
gratuitous there's a difference between
hyper violent and gratuity i thought the
violence in the show
always served a purpose for the most
part shocking yes but it was effectively
shocking in that
my jaw just hit the floor kind of way
whether it's effectively shocking you
or shocking characters in the story
because you are not the characters in
the story
shocking you doesn't mean they get
shocked them getting shocked doesn't
mean you're shocked a show
movie video game any form of
entertainment that's telling a story
has to differentiate those two elements
and this show does a good job at keeping
you both in the loop and keeping you
both on your toes whether it be shocking
you
shocking the characters or using the
violence
to lend perspective there were more than
a few times invincible where
if the show wasn't as violent as it was
the point wouldn't have been hit home as
it was it's a very real technique and
invincible does it i don't want to say
flawlessly but i might very well say
flawlessly
also the show's really darkly funny you
know
i mean it's funny in a way that's not a
comedy you know what i mean i have to
explain it because if i'm saying oh yeah
the superhero
movie or show also was funny then it
just sounds like oh you mean they turned
it into a comedy
not that i guess what i'm trying to say
is the show has very good timing when it
comes to a fight maybe someone gets hit
when it goes from smooth animation to
that one frame
wow someone just hits a building like
that like in a micro
second good timing also good timing in
the dialogue which the animation feeds
into
guys in the end invincible is incredible
on the surface it's an awesome kick-ass
superhero ride the fights are exciting
the animation's top-notch but that's
just the icing on the cake deep down
it is great grade a solid relatable
interesting
character storytelling the stakes are
enormous the choices are heavy and the
violence is so amazingly unhinged i'm
only showing you select
scenes in this video from about half of
the trailer i say give this a shot if
you have that feeling of like
everything superheroes down it's all
superheroes and spin off the superheroes
i've seen enough superhero stuff
watch at least the first episode and if
by the end of that first episode
you're not like i'm interested in
watching more
i i guess it won't grab you but if it
does grab you
that's why watch the first episode all
right so invincible have you seen it
what well wait a minute
usually i'd say comment below let me
know in which case people who haven't
seen it are going to go down to the
comment section be like i haven't seen
it then they're going to see spoilers i
promise you they're going to be spoilers
in the comments section so if you
haven't seen the show
just stay away from the comment section
like at all costs however comments in
the comment section do help a youtube
video get
circulation so if you want to dip down
to the comment section comment something
like that then bounce you'd be really
helping my video out in terms of the
algorithm but as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more
click right here to see more
you